you heard right folks there's free DLC
for pvz on the way and no the so-called
garden-variety pack isn't just three
dozen more outfits for your adorable
little sunflower I mean it kind of is
there are a bunch of new cosmetic
options but it's the alternate abilities
and the new competitive mode that'll
really cultivate your interests glance
after all combat in garden warfare is
all about smart ability use to get your
mind laying you're teleporting and speed
boosting on point and you're in great
shape you can easily plan your defensive
strategy because you can tell at a
glance what abilities your enemies are
bringing to bear unto now the garden
variety pack includes alternate versions
of every ability for every plant and
every zombie many of these new abilities
are just small tweaks through the
strength and duration of the existing
abilities like the pea shooters chili
bean bomb which now takes longer
explodes bigger and wears a saucy
sombrero or the all-stars ultra tackle
which is more damaging but takes longer
to recharge other alternate abilities
are more significant strategic tweaks
the engineers sonic grenades become
Sonic Minds which puts you in a more
defensive mindset the sunflowers heal
flower turns into the sinister dark
flower dealing damage to enemies with
lasers instead of healing allies with
happy stars none of the abilities really
feel like straight upgrades and they're
not meant to be you may find yourself
switching back to the original abilities
after trying the new ones and not really
liking them some even feel like a
potential step back like the scientists
sluggish free roaming energy warp still
it's nice to have some new stuff to play
around with and this extends to the new
mode no mom no mom is a garden II take
on the multiplayer shooter classic grab
the bomb and carry it to the enemy thing
mode bring old Nomi to one of the three
enemy targets and it instantly arms
leaving you and your team to defend it
from diffuse attempts for 30 seconds at
their best these matches are lively
intense as the fighting moves
frantically around the map with both
teams struggling to gain the advantage
of course there are some one-sided
clashes too especially if a team regular
he puts up strong defenses around there
planted bombs honestly though it's just
nice to have another competitive option
to join team vanquish and gardens and
graveyards oh and there's a new map to a
pretty basic little village where team
vanquish and gnome bomb matches play out
on the streets and rooftops the garden
variety pack is available Tuesday March
18th for free
so hey download it and give the new
stuff a whirl why not it's nice to see
this entertaining little shooter getting
some DLC love and nice that it doesn't
involve microtransactions yet thanks for
watching and happy chomping